hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
excellent game to share with you from
the 2019 Tata steel chess India rapid
and Blitz event this is a five minute
game with the two second increment
on the wide end Magnus Carlson
and he's playing against dingler in
so we have an E4 E5 game Roy Lopez
and on this move 6 the delayed
exchange variation
black takes away from the center
this guy is now ready to play
D3
if you go ahead and grab on E5 in this
case
we're just exchanging pawns black can
recapture
capture on the E4 Square
so once it's secure now black must tend
to E5 and does with Knight D7 the
beginning of
a maneuver
to the knight's favorite Square E6
both sides will enjoy having a night on
these two squares they work well they
coordinate well
with the fixed pons E4 and E5
from here Knight V to D2
castles
A4 is met with A5 black does not want to
see this Pawn get to A5 it can have a
cramping effect
on Black's Queen side structure so it
stopped cold
from here B3
F6
and now Knight to H4 did you notice what
just happened there
these little details
as soon as F6 is in and E5 is secure
this Knight is no longer effective in
restricting the Knight
wipe now makes the decision to
eye up a new square for the Knight tries
to get this guy working on F5 and it
also frees the way
for the f-pawn to advance
there's one thing about this position
that sticks out to me and it's the Rooks
they don't yet function
each side still needs in other words to
create a pawn break
nearby there can be F4
Knight C5 Knight F5 Knight E6
and Knight to C4
from here B6
securing A5 and also we're ready to
fincet of the bishop this is the
unopposed bishop
and it's almost always
a good idea
or rarely is a bad idea I should say to
develop the unopposed bishop on the
longest diagonal
from here we have Knight takes Bishop
this is considered a best move
it sort of grabbed my attention this
decision because
you know why why exactly are you giving
up the night for Bishop this guy seems
pretty good on F5
I think it's related to
this idea where if you if you don't take
the bishop right now let's say play
Queen E2
it may be the case black doesn't give
you a second chance to take that Bishop
and now it may be the case these guys
are sort of stepping on one another's
toes they're all competing for this
great Square E3 and only one of them
could ever make use of it
and now white would have to wonder where
am I going with the Knight after G6
do I go forward this may seem aggressive
but in a way it could be
not so well placed do I go back to G3
okay it could be that they're stepping
on one another's toes so he doesn't give
black a second chance to save the bishop
he takes on this move 14.
Queen takes Knight
E3 mission accomplished for both nights
from here G6 cutting out a square
that leaves this diagonal a bit more
weakened F6
is now a whole we can say so
this is a move that in a way prompts
White's reply to put the bishop on the
long diagonal
okay it's x-raying a hole on F6 we might
say
from here C5
and now Queen to D2 so one of the
squares that is now available to
white after C5 is the D5 Square
the Knight could jump in there and it
certainly seems appealing
you land in Black's Camp you generate a
threat
what would Black's reply be to Knight to
D5 I want to highlight this again the
move played in the game is Queen D2 if
this Knight hops in here
the best reply is for the queen to go
back home
and I want to draw your attention to
this position here because
it's
I think it may open your eyes to
a new way to think about the game
let's say in this position now black
follows up with the move they played in
the game Queen to D2
if you're trying to sneak in F4 by the
way the Knight will be kicked away from
its defensive F4 and black would be
winning a pawn
so let's say queen D2
now we could see the point with the
queen going back home the Knight is
kicked with C3 The Queen Is Watching
Over B6 from her home square there's no
Knight takes Pawn
the Knight would be kicked back and now
watch how you could go ahead and in a
way it's going to sound weird in a way
develop your Bishop
how do you normally develop your Queen
Bishop by moving it
so that the queen Rook could move well
what if we switch that
a good move in this position is a rook
lift to A7
let's just say we have a sort of passing
move in here Rook A7 to G7 and with this
last move
black has essentially developed the
bishop this is a productive piece
99 of the time when we move a Queen
Bishop it is
so that we can next develop the queen
Rook well the queen Rook has already
developed
the Queen Bishop is now playing it's not
interfering with development
so it's an interesting way to maybe view
development this idea of C6 Rook A7 to
G7 this guy's playing
okay black has a good answer to Knight
to D5 Queen goes home
in the game it's Queen to D2
Bishop B7
Rook a to E1 Rook a to d8 and F3
where 19 moves in this is only a 35 move
game
here is dingleren's brilliant idea in
action
he goes for a king walk
King F7
now about 58 seconds was spent on this
move
and Carlson's reply took him about a
minute 20. really cannot afford
many more things like this for either
side again it's only a five minute game
two second increment
where's the king headed to the queen
side one two
three
four if the king could get to C8 that
would be wonderful for black
ding Lauren expressed after the game
that he didn't see how else to improve
his position
the Rooks are pretty well placed the
bishop is good night is good so
improving the king it's going to take a
long while it's gonna take four Tempe
does black have the time
to get this in
now the things to consider before going
for a king walk such as this
first of all why is having the king over
on C8 in Improvement
well it's a healthier structure on the
queen side
this right here ties in beautifully with
the light Square Bishop
a dream setup for Black would be to have
the bishop on C6
and the King on B7
and when that Arrangement is in this
Pawn right here on C7 guards the king
against rank checks this guy here guards
the king against file checks and the
bishop on C6 defends the king against
diagonal checks
additionally this C5 Pawn only adds to
the king's defense
in some situations if there's let's say
a half open C file there's no sacrifice
so there's no moves like Rook takes
Bishop to disrupt that formation
so it is a very strong Safe Haven
for the black king to be on the queen
side
right here it's weakened after G6 is in
there we have an unopposed dark Square
Bishop
it's safer on the queen side now the
bulk of his time
thinking about this idea I believe is
related to
the timing do I have the time to get
this maneuver in
It's Quickly recognized that this is the
superior side of the board for the king
what's going through his mind is likely
how might white interfere with this
might there be a quick opening up of the
position do I have under control the
pawn breaks D4 and F4
black does have a good grip over both
notice the E5 Pawn C5 Pawn Knight Rook
they all
contribute to stopping the two key Pawn
breaks F4 and D4 this is the best
move in the position King F7
white has to come up with something fast
against this idea and so shifts the
queen towards the king side
and tries to quickly put pressure on
these dark squares to put
to try and interfere with this plan
and at this point feels compelled to
give up some material just to open the
open the position and gain access to the
weakest point in Black's Camp F6
F4 is played
Knight takes F4 computer at this stage
suggests best play is G3
followed by the doubling of the Rooks
not easy to follow up in this way
Carlson feels like it's best to give up
even more material give up the exchange
and go after F6
from here we have G5 Queen H6
maintaining pressure on F6
King E6 or excuse me Queen E6
Knight takes F6 check
ing to C1
wanna pause for a moment
take note of this position right here
is there anything that sticks out to you
about this position
I don't want to say anything more
we're soon going to revisit this after I
complete going through the game
okay we're going to revisit this just
curious what maybe sticks out to you
about it
in the game we have Queen takes G5 this
is where it starts to go way downhill
for white there's an idea that was
missed
considered better is Rook to F1 which
keeps a very close eye on the F Pawn
after Queen takes G5
an excellent move
F3 is played
and what's the story here trying to
disrupt
the pawn Duo
if white takes on F3
the G file is now opened
and the Queen and King are on it
so black would be able to follow with
Rook G8
Rook takes Knight give back a little bit
material but you're going to be getting
it back
you're going to be getting the queen
or if white doesn't want to give up the
queen they'd have to go into a self pin
and that will that would be taken
advantage of with Queen to D7 and the
bishop is soon going to fall
black will be up a bishop
so
white does not bite on F3
he plays Rook F1
Rook G8 still giving back the material
in order to get the Rook on G2 with
check
have to be careful don't go all in right
here as black with Queen H3
Queen H3 ducking the queen exchange well
you're gonna get mated
so
Queen G6 forming a battery also with the
Nyan
defense
from here H4 there's really not much you
can do as white
he's trying to with this last move
challenge the queen post
some other move like Rook to C1 well
that's not
any fun
babysitting the pawn like this
black could continue with F2 and there's
not a good
answer to Rook to G1
so let's play this H4 and we're almost
there with our Dream setup one move here
Bishop to C6
look at this pocket the king in this
game never ends up arriving on B7 but
it's only ever one move out
the square is now open for the king the
bishop also stops any check which means
this queen is now ready to slip into G4
and H3 we don't need the queen
to defend to defend our own King at this
point we're ready to go all in for this
mating attack
white defends that with Queen F4
Rook takes Pawn
Rook G1 Rook G2 you can't take the Rook
it's gonna be mate
the bishop is also hit
in the game we have Queen E3
if white tries something else
such as Rook to B1 I want to highlight a
few variations
from here that black could go forward
with
you can start with Rook G4
and if white gets tries to get the
Queens off like this we can exchange
Queens follow up with the discovered
check
another check don't go here you're gonna
get hit with the double check
King H3 Rook G1 black will be promoting
very soon
some other line
is this one right here
after Rook G4 Queen H2 defending Rook
takes H4 black can sacrifice the bishop
and now look at all the threats that are
there hitting the Rook setting up a
skewer setting up a discovered check
white doesn't have an answer to that
and finally
if black plays a move like Queen F6
we would have a mate in two with a
clearance sacrifice get out of the way
the Rook
because we want to get into G2 for me
so this one played out with Queen E3
simply defending Rook takes Rook
one final move Queen G3
white resigns
what do you do
how do you stop
one two three four maintenance ones
you don't
so this is a very nice game and I want
to go back
to this move
or this one position where I said is
there anything that sticks out to you
so that is this position right here
this grabbed my attention in preparing
for this video going through this game
is there a way to improve upon this
plan by black
how did we get to where we currently are
here with the King on C8 and Rook on d8
how many moves did it take in this game
well there was castles that's one
Rook d8 2 and then the king maneuver
three four five six
is this arrangement maybe possible
in just one move
this is exactly where these pieces end
up when you do what
Queen side Castle
I'm not saying that black can
save five moves
or maybe I am
is it possible to
get this arrangement
in some cases
in just one move
can this be improved upon
if we go back to this position right
here the first moment where black made
the decision to Castle may it may make
some sense for you to keep this idea in
mind
it may make sense for you to not Castle
so soon
could you get away with playing F6 here
you certainly can let's say similar
moves were played in the game
and we go for this maneuver you may have
to flick in some different move here
this is a spot where white could maybe
give a check and there's going to be a
problem you may have to flick this move
in
but you could still maybe hint at a
different deployment for the bishop
Queen D7 and castles that too Can Be an
Effective plan
it's something to keep in mind
you may find castling Queen side
is a good idea so at least give yourself
the option to do just that you may find
yourself you may find that you save
yourself a move
or five
anyhow some food for thought
Feel Free as usual to leave any feedback
to this video in the comment section
below I hope you enjoyed it and maybe
took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
foreign